hi my name is Wilma National Geography
behind me you can see how to two of a
diverse amis that marks the head over
castle and the carl theodor very horny
old bridge however castle is well
between 1400 and 15
train 17 86 and 17
as you can see how to Berg is very
beautiful city and situated on earth
in their current value
we are now standing in one of several
squares in my kid is named after 12 feet
or the most famous Ben selectivity of
any beginning of the box truck sir what
is it really good
and it is one of the longest in
it is another one
a great
shops we are also standing at the edge
of marks which markets player as you can
see the open air market base our
favorite objectives and tourists can
also see that one of two cathedrals
Edinburgh Church of the Holy Ghost
see
when you stop all future concerts
occasionally
a honda room you also find Germany Joe
Louis University however university was
established in early 1300 on me you
cannot see the university library inside
you will find some years most rare and
valuable books so we'll how do you
remember all these various facts about
geography well I just kind of read and
remember
so in your studies what is one of the
most unique facts that you've come
across are interesting facts well I
found it very interesting that China has
more English speakers in the US
the will if you someone were to give you
a free ticket to anywhere in the world
where would you go and what would you do
while you were there well someone gave
me a burger I would go to st. Petersburg
Russia become a very interested in
Russian history and culture and it
represents the westernization of Russia
and reveals it is most western city in
Russia and architecture while I was that
if i were there first I would go to the
Winter Palace which is now an art museum
and look at the art there and I would go
to the patron paul fortress which was
the main fortress Peter the Great built
there to protect the harbor that he's
captured from the Swedes and then I
would go to the church of the saviour on
spilled blood which is a church that was
built on the site where Alexander the
second was Tsar Alexander second
exercise me sounds like a very
interesting trip so if you were made
world leader of the world for a day what
problem did you try and solve and why
Ireland judge the world for day I would
try and solve the world energy problem I
would do that by gathering the world's
greatest minds
and coming up with the most expected
effective and inexpensive way of
reducing the use of fossil fuels and
increase in the use of alternatives like
one solder and hydroelectric power and
by also increasing the use of bio fuels
is that instead of fossil fuels
you